my colleague from the nfl media group
ian rappaport joining us here on an
incredibly busy wednesday in between
weeks eight and nine right here on the
rich island show how are you ian
i'm good rich i want to say right off
the bat that um
if something happens where i need to
take a phone call during this segment
please don't murder me like that
washington dc radio host once did i
promise you it is only for news that
might be happening today okay
so i apologize in advance if i get a
phone call which may or may not have
okay anyway hi ian you're you're a busy
man in an incredibly busy time so let's
get right down to it um
i give you the floor on the aaron
rodgers news what do you know and um how
do you know as best you can tell and and
what it means go forward so i i heard
you guys talking before i got on um
rogers has not lied to the packers or to
the nfl
they have known that he's unvaccinated
for the entire season and i think a lot
of people have and roger's you know sort
of dancing around the question saying
he's immunized
uh is a way of answering the question
but obviously more notable it's a way of
not answering the question but it is not
lying he has from what i understand
followed the
protocols on
for unvaccinated players he has followed
those the entire season which is wearing
a mask inside he has been spotted
at press conferences not wearing a mask
there have been other press conferences
where a husband had a mask around his
neck so i don't know what the difference
between one press conference or another
is maybe there is a press conference
setting that's outside or i don't i'm
not there but i know that he has
followed protocols for unvaccinated
players uh through most of the season
uh the nfl has known this anyway and you
know this is something that i came
across a couple weeks ago
um
and this is all sort of coming up today
so that is what i know he tested
positive he is out on sunday jordan will
assume he also doesn't test positively
gonna start on sunday rogers is out at
least until saturday of next week so he
could play next week but he's not gonna
play this week
okay so um
so it's possible that do you know if
love's vaccinated because you know being
a close contact i imagine being in a in
a quarterback room
i mean where where would that stand
right now i
i do not know for sure but i believe if
he was
unvaccinated we would know it by now
right that then because he'd be a close
con unless they unless
i don't know i mean unless rogers wasn't
around the facility and they weren't
around each other i mean there's just an
insane amount of speculation and
remember kurt banker who i mean i know
you guys are following the kurt banker's
situation very closely um
he tested positive for kobe yeah
yesterday
so i believe that is where this came
from i mean who really knows but right
two quarterbacks have tested positive
attackers one just like rogers one
happens no you know with all due respect
to kurt banker yeah right one happens to
be aaron rodgers okay so um
so
what's what's the upshot here i mean
the point is of him being unvaccinated
is what then you know like as if your
test positive for covid you could still
be back there if you're vaccinated if
you get on if you get two tests that are
negative somehow between one time and
another right is that what it is right i
mean that's the thing like if you know
and i know there's certainly a debate
about all of this you know
for
you know for aaron rodgers like and
people i think you know some fans will
be upset about us talking about his
personal choices when it involves your
football team it is not personal when it
affects your teammates
when it negatively affects your
teammates and your fans
and your friends is not personal it is a
team decision of aaron rodgers to not
get vaccinated so
he has
and this is not and this is literally a
fact this is not a criticism he has hurt
the team by not being vaccinated that is
a fact if he was vaccinated there'd be a
chance he'd be able to play on sunday
ian rappaport here uh on the rich eisen
show let's get to the uh other news of
the day odell beckham is not at practice
for the cleveland browns a team-excused
absence what is going on with odell and
the browns
i
i don't know
all i know is that he was listed as a
non-injury reason to practice
why the absence is i do not know i mean
i know some things but i'm i cannot
confirm that it was excused by the team
or
what led to it or anything what i do
know is that he is not there right now
for reasons not involving the ac joint
sprain that he has in the shoulder so
what is the obviously what's the latest
i mean was
why wasn't he traded and and what what
happens now do you think you know he
wasn't traded because it's hard to trade
for really expensive players who are not
playing well
i mean if you think about it the only
really expensive player who was traded
was von miller
and he was traded because
the bro the broncos paid most of his
salary and took a second and third round
pit board
you know like
that's
that's that's why he was traded i mean
guys who are not playing well who are
very expensive didn't get traded this
year because
everyone's tight against the cap and
that's that i mean i know you know i
mean i guess the saints looked into it
but they couldn't have looked into it
for that long because i don't know how
that would work money-wise
so and i don't think the browns were
gonna eat money
so it's not a good situation um
and i don't know how it's going to end
either i mean
what's odell beckham's future like in
cleveland it's not like the offense has
been making good use of him already
right so like what's the point right
that's and that is the point so what
what about his relationship with baker
uh
apparently they were playing
video games on jarvis landry's feed last
night right so i i don't think they have
a bad relationship i really don't right
i know this sounds stupid but i really
don't i just think if they don't have a
good football relationship
you know like you can be friends with
someone and just not mesh well on the
field
you can be friends with someone and
just not be in sync you know like it
almost has nothing
everybody likes odell
you know
uh i i just think it's more they have
not been able to connect football wise
and we've seen a lot of evidence to show
that it is not a small sample size
anymore so is it possible they can just
release him or you know
in the nba this this would lead to you
know uh just
a contract being what um bought out
and um what if odell helps buy himself
out right what if odell just tells the
browns
let's come up with some sort of
financial settlement where you don't pay
i mean if he's going to give up if he's
going to give up money i'm sure they
would be open to it but
you know i don't i would be surprised if
odell would give up money nobody should
give up money
so
i mean how is it going to end
i don't know but my guess is it's not
going to end within dancing in the end
zone after catching the touchdown pastor
baker mayfield but we will see
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show
um because i think he would be
he would if he showed up on a bunch of
other teams i think we'd find out that
he still has some gas left in the tank
for sure
um what are the saints
i do absolutely i think that yeah you
don't
i i don't know i'm trying to figure this
out and i say this as someone who has
always been a fan of o'dell just like as
a well as a person but i was a player
mostly
um
i
i mean
look
we see this all the time when you know
fans will be clamoring for some players
on the sidelines why won't they play
this guy along with the play this guy
then you see the guy get in and you're
like oh i see why they haven't played
them
um i'm sure baker mayfield would want to
throw to a very good player who gets
open and will score touchdown
the fact that he's not isn't personal to
me it just means
it might not be those things
ian rap report here on the rich eisen
show i i i was so stunned yesterday
um
with the news that you were tweeting out
about the sean watson not the fact that
they couldn't strike a deal desean
watson and the texans and the dolphins
together but the fact that the owner of
the dolphin stephen ross finally got
permission to speak to deshaun watson
only the night before
how did it take that long for two teams
that have been dancing around each other
with the subject matter that is so
obvious that the risk of acquiring him
needed to be removed for everybody to
get what they wanted to sean in miami
and and desean putting himself in miami
the texans getting him off their roster
and getting dollar for dollar not cents
on the dollar how how did it take that
long for steven ross to sit down
with deshaun watson
well because
it's because these this thing had a
had a deadline and a
life of its own
and
it happens when it happens and i know
that's a bad answer but
this thing had tops and turns and false
starts and i mean think about how many
times people have reported a deal was
going to happen and then it didn't end
up happening it needed to be close
enough
and
real enough for the owner to get
permission to sit down so i think that's
what it was it took that long for the
two sides to say you know what
now this actually may happen
now you can do it
and
it came the night before they still
could have done it certainly could have
done it
but from what i understand the most
sort of the biggest reason that
um
deshaun watson did not end up as a miami
dolphin today is because he has not
settled his cases yet and martin has
maintained his innocence
and he has not settled his cases and
that is why he is
from what i understand not a member of
the dolphins well i mean
so
um maybe i guess they're also holding
off stephen ross because of what a
problem it might create uh with tua even
though it's obvious that they were
trying to get watson for weeks and
months
and the coach and brian flores says it
too is our guy and now
he meets with him and it still doesn't
happen
so now what you know
that's tough one to put back in the
bottle
yeah kind of i kind of go back i mean i
you're obviously not wrong but i i just
personally i kind of go back and forth
on that
because like
isn't life just like all of us waiting
to be replaced by somebody who's better
than us
wow you just went like full kyle
shanahan we may all be dead sunday what
does it matter about deshaun watson
anyway
seriously it's true like right i mean
like for all of us it's like we all are
amazing at our jobs and life is so good
unless they find somebody better in
which case that person will be doing it
that's what life is like right like so i
think i don't get the sense honestly i
don't think two really cares that much i
think he's really fun actually that
sounds crazy but i think he's really
fine that's just the reality of life
like and i don't even know that it's a
two issue like i don't think the
dolphins i got to suck so we're gonna go
get watson i think it's like oh my god
we might actually be able to get to sean
watson let's look into this like i it's
just
i mean we're all replaceable if there's
someone else better it's just the
reality i don't know no and i know that
you could say that is life in the big
city but when you're already you know uh
in for such a huge draft choice for
for your quarterback
and your draft choice in next year's
draft your top draft choice and next
year's draft belongs to somebody else
uh this one will be tough to be to fix
unless you just say screw it by next
march
next new league year boy will we be all
the way in on on watson then when you
hope that things will be a little bit
more rectified and it winds up in a way
that oh by the way
watson is a viable citizen not just a
football player um so
that's one way to do it
but
what would the market be now that the
can has officially been kicked down the
road what about that leverage that the
texans may have the dolphins may have
anyway regardless of how many teams are
interested because watson only wants to
go to miami or was that just for now
what can you tell me about that part of
the equation that we're going to
eventually
land on next new league year ian
i think the market's going to be
stronger
like that's that's always been like
i'm not going to say they almost had a
deal but they could have had a deal
yesterday and there were definitely
times when i thought a deal was getting
done
um
the fact that it didn't it didn't but
it's always struck me that it actually
benefited the texans by waiting like it
really did like they because you know
like the panthers
would have been in it
and they probably will be in this
offseason the dolphins i would assume
are still going to be in it this off
season but
think about how many teams are going to
need quarterbacks
like
there's i mean i could go right down the
list and i'll just say like i do not
know i'm not this is not news here but i
have no idea of the falcons how
committed they are to matt ryan whether
they be interested in all that
but that's where deshawn is from they do
have a quarterback that's aging like
would they be interesting to him
like there's going to be some real teams
that are interested so i think the
market's actually going to be better
right uh unless he is just so focused on
miami he creates the market himself he
you know i mean that's that's
that's part of this whole rubik's cube
that
that still hasn't been solved you know
um and then of course there's a
possibility that aaron rodgers is out
there for some teams too
i mean that's what makes aaron rodgers
russell wilson like there's you know we
could go all the way down the list
wow you know what are you hearing last
one for you what are you hearing that
sean payton's doing with his quarterback
spot is it going to be simeon what do
you what do you think he's going to wind
up with on that front
ian um
my
my sense not a source telling me but
just my sense from the situation that
it's going to be simeon
i think that's the guy that sean payton
liked
i also don't know if uh taysom hill is
going to practice today i'd like to find
that out first because
um
he is still recovering from a concussion
and if he doesn't practice it that would
certainly mean that was similar but
i just know how much
sean payton likes trevor simeon john
peyton really likes someone who would
just do what he tells them to do
uh which as do i by the way is just
harder to find in my house
um
and so i think he likes trevor siemian
because he does everything sean tells
him to do and he actually played really
well the other day and michael thomas
you're you you were first today um to
say that there was something up other
than just his surgically repaired ankle
and then boom
out comes a um a tweet from
a statement from thomas that he's done
for the year ian that stinks as well
yeah
and i have to say like i had the news
this morning and i thought he was done
for the season but i couldn't quite say
it because i just didn't have enough
proof
so i said what i knew which is that it's
not good and he's out indefinitely and
his return is unclear and then michael
thomas decided to trump me with his own
news right um
so you know i'm not the saints are going
to be okay but you know losing one of
the best players in the nfl and not
having him come back is
not great okay well i mean i don't mean
to press my luck because we have gone
through this entire conversation with
you out having to jump to go get the
call that you you were you were saying
you might get saquon barkley's got
covered now did that literally just
happen oh he is yeah uh i was tweeting
that as i was pretending to listen to
your first answer thank you um
yeah um
so yeah he tested positive based on the
first test so he is not at practice one
of the players
who is now going through retesting to
see if he's still test positive based on
the re-test if he is vaccinated
unlike a certain long-haired quarterback
so
there is a possibility that he plays on
sunday if his ankle is healthy enough to
do it which we don't know right so two
negative tests within 24 hours because
he is vaccinated with no symptoms means
that he could get on the field against
the las vegas raiders
correct correct and if he was
unvaccinated that means it doesn't
matter you're you're finished for the
rest of the week right but he was
vaccinated okay
anything else did i miss anything your
brother
so you're good you're fine you're good
because i mean you know we're all
replaceable um yeah all that business
people aren't listening to you in your
house i mean
i heard that one life man okay yeah
that's well i'm i i'm i am at peace with
my life okay very good all right ian
thanks for the call greatly appreciate
it you're the best thanks brother
talk to you that's the enrap board at
rap sheet
right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here